[Müzik]
evet ben kulististan buraya çıkana kadar
milyonlarca insan karar verdi Kimileri
ayrıldı Kimileri evlendi Kimileri işini
terk etti Kimileri okulunu değiştirmek
istedi Kimileri yeni bir işe başladı
Bunlar bireysel olarak düşündüğümüzde o
kararı veren ve etkilenen kişiyi
etkiledi Aslında temelde karşısındaki
kişiyi etkiledi Ama tüm dünyaya da
baktığınızda tüm dünyayı da etkileyen
bir karar mekanizması oluşturdular Bu
kararlar bütün dünyayı etkilemeye
başladı Aslında insanın vücudunda da
öyle farklı fikirler var bizim aklımızda
binlerce bağımsız Fikri binlerce
bağımsız davranışı gerçekleştiriyoruz ve
bu bağımsız davranışlar sonunda
birleşiyor bizim karakterimize
kişiliğimizi davranış şeklimizi
oluşturuyor olaylara da Aslında buradaki
davranış şeklimize kişiliğimize göre
karar vermeye başlıyoruz olaylara tepki
vermeye başlıyoruz
bir ev hayal edin Şimdi harika bir ev
inşa etmek istiyoruz birlikte
arkada gördüğünüz ev gibi olabilir
birlikte yapacağız bunu
harika bir tasarımcı olabiliriz Mimar
olabiliriz Biz kendimiz de sayacağız ya
da birine tasarlattıracağız ama inşa
etmek bizim görevimiz
elimizde tuğlalar verdiler tuğlalara
baktık çok çirkin görünüyorlar Az önceki
evi Ev kadar güzel değiller
Ama bunlar inşaatın en küçük parçaları
eğer biz bu en küçük parçalara
odaklanmazsak o evi oluşturamayacağımızı
farkına varmalıyız elimizde küçük
tuğlalar var 3 tane tuğlayı bir araya
koyduğunuzda kaygıyla oturup ya bu
tuğlalar asla bu eve dönüşmez ben ne
yaptım şimdi bu tuğlalarla başlanır
mıydı derseniz o evi hiçbir zaman inşa
edemeyeceksiniz Aslında benim de
yolculuğum tamamen böyle başladı
Adana'da çok da kolay olmayan zorlu bir
hayatta büyüdüm ben üniversiteyi
kazandım ODTÜ'de endüstri mühendi okudum
O yüzden o türün resmini arkaya koydum
üniversite başladım iyi bir bölümdeyim
derslerde aktifim Bayağı iş stajlar
yapmaya başladım Daha hazırlıktan Ama
şunu fark ettim Ben ne yaparsam yapayım
hayal ettiğim noktaya ulaşamayacak gibi
hissediyorum kaygı var içimde ve sürekli
ya Ben mezun olduğumda ne yapacağım
şimdi neyi seçmeliyim ya da işe girdim
acaba o işte mutlu olacak mıyım
pazarlamaya mı odaklansam satışa mi
odaklansam gibi kaygılarla geçirmeye
başladım günlerime ve şunu düşündüm
Sonra aslında yanlış yapıyorum Bir
sonraki seneye odaklanmalıyım ben küçük
parçalara bölmeliyim bu işi ya da bir
sonraki aya Ben şu an insanların
yapmadığı benim daha iyi yapabileceğim
ve insanlara da fayda sağlayacak neler
yapabilirim bunlara odaklanmaya başladım
başta bir sosyal sorumluluk projesi oldu
bu ODTÜ'de bir Arge topluluğuyla başladı
böyle tetiks organize eden ekiplerde yer
aldım
sahnede olmak bambaşka bu arada
tedx organizeden ekiplerde yer aldım
Universe Force isminde bir sosyal
sorumluluk projesini hayata geçirdim
sonra insanlar şunu söylemeye başladı ya
bir anda dersim var çok iyi şirketlerde
gidip çalışabilirsin niye sosyal
sorumluluk projeleri ile uğraşıyorsun
neden vakit harcıyorsun ama benim o an
düşüncem ve yolculuğun bambaşkaydı Çünkü
ben şuna İnanıyordum bugün yaptığım
herhangi bir şey yarın bir gün bana
bambaşka yönlerle faydalı olabilir o
yüzden bugünün boş geçmesin de ben
herhangi bir şey yapayım Ama ne
yapıyorsam yapayım farklı bir şey
yapayım ha odaklandım her sene bir
önceki seneden daha iyi Ne yapabiliyorum
ana konumdu Aslında baktığımızda Buna da
şöyle karar verdim okuduğum hikayeler
hep onu gösteriyordu bu Facebook'un 2004
senesindeki ekranı
şu ekrana Bakın Şu an girişimciliğe
başlayan birçok insan
insanların başarılı girişimcilerinin şu
anda bulunduğu konuma bakıyorlar
harika bir uygulama yapmış Trendyol şu
an milyar dolarlık bir şirket diyoruz
Acaba ilk sitesi nasıldı nasıl başladı
küçük tuğlaları neydi onun birazcık
oraya bakmak gerekiyor Mark şunu
söyleseydi Ya ben metaforce yapmak
istiyorum dünyayı değiştirmek istiyorum
Instagram gibi bir şeyi satın almak
istiyorum Belki o zamanlar bunu bile
hayal edemiyordu ama o zaman yaptığı şu
basit sitede bile buna odaklandı bunu en
iyi yapmaya odaklandı Nitekim
Jeff bezos da öyle
şu an çok güçlü bir şirket Ama son ama
ilk başladığında Jeff bezos kitap
sarıyordu
kitap bantlayan kitapları kolyeleyen bir
adam düşünün O an şunu söyleseydi Ya ben
Milyarder Olmak için ayrıldım Bu
şirketten kitap mı sereceğim ya buraya
her gün geliyorum
hiç de beğenmediğim bir ortamdayım tozlu
kitaplar içerisindeyim bunları sürekli
sarıyorum insanlara satmaya çalışıyorum
derdimiz kitap mıydı deseydi emin olun
bugünkü geldiği noktaya gelemezdi
şimdi bizim de genelde konumuz bu
yolculuğa odaklanmak yolculuk insanların
başlangıç noktası var sonuna doğru
gidiyor
sonuna doğru yürürken de aslında o
aradaki yaptığınız eylemlerin ne
yapıyorsanız yapın En iyi yapmak en
önemli konulardan birisi Tamam küçük
parçalara odaklandık bir de bunu sürekli
geliştirmek var arkamda bir video
görüyorsunuz
tekrar tıklayın başladı
şunu söyleyebilirsiniz bunlar zaten
varlıktı Petrol zengin insanlar Tabii ki
İnşaat yaparlar tabii ki sürekli
güzelleştirirler bulundukları yere ama
bir fark var arkamdaki videoda şunu
görüyorsunuz yaptıkları her bina bir
sonraki bina her bir sonraki bina bir
öncekinden daha iyi
bir öncekinden daha iyi yapmaya
çalışıyorlar sürekli geliştirmeye
çalışıyorlar Yani aslında evet yolculuk
var tuğlaları dizeceğiz biz tek tek ama
o aynı tuğlaları her seferinde aynı
şekilde yaparak da olmuyor bu iş
başladık bu yolcuda bir önceki tuğladan
daha iyi Ne yapıyorsun Daha iyi nasıl
koyabilirsin o tuğlayı Birazcık da orayı
düşünmemiz gerekiyor şimdi
parçalar var sürekli de gelişiyoruz ama
en önemli konuya geldik arkamda anka
kuşu var bilmiyorum Anka kuşunun
hikayesini biliyor musunuz Ama ben biraz
özetleyeyim konuyu tekrar Bütün kuşlar
Anka kuşunun varlığına inanıyor hepsi
diyor ki ben Anka kuşunu bulursam O
benim hayalimi gerçekleştirecek Anka
kuşuna gitmeliyiz Ne istiyorsak
söylemeliyiz O da bizim hayalimizi
gerçekleştirmedi
sonrasında yolculuğa çıkıyorlar 7 tane
vadiden geçiyorlar bu 7 Vadi istek
Vadisi Aşk Vadisi marifet Vadisi istisna
Vadisi diye gidiyor ve kuşların bazıları
bu vadilerde kayboluyorlar isteği az
olan dünyevi şeylere çok takılan
insanlar örneğin istek vadisinde
kalıyorlar en son 30 Kuş varıyor
Kaf Dağı'na ve fark ediyorlar ki anka
kuşu diye bir şey yok aslında o
vadilerden geçmeleri onların içinde anka
kuşu gücünü oluşturdu yani ne isterlerse
artık Yapabilirler çünkü o yolculuktaki
deneyim onlara bunu sağladı şimdi Hadi
biz de bugünden sonra bu etkinlikten
sonra Yolun sonundaki Anka kuşunu Hayal
edelim ama yolculuğumuza odaklanalım
belki de bizim de içimizde İlhan ka kuşu
vardır Teşekkür ederim dinlediğiniz için
[Müzik]